at the part of styling er cargo ships
arrive around the clock for loading and
unloading that allows offshore oil
production to continue uninterrupted
nevertheless fewer ships come here now
than just a year ago the oil companies
are cutting costs particularly when it
comes to exploring new oil fields truck
driver Mar and sky Holland is concerned
about the future of her job until now
job cuts were unheard of in the booming
oil industry but now a number of
companies are starting to lay off staff
there's a lot of engineers and office
personnel it's lost their jobs but right
now with the drivers and us working out
here we haven't lost their jobs yet we
still have plenty to do stopping her is
the largest center of oil and gas
exploration in the North Sea the
construction of new houses and office
blocks continues apace here in stopping
her some 50,000 people are employed
directly by the oil industry the local
university has also specialized in
training engineers for the industry
these students are learning how to test
drill samples for crude oil until
recently they were guaranteed a job at
the end of their studies but in recent
months the labour market has changed the
student says he's now concerned about
his future and he's by no means alone
getting opportunities early but not the
moment in Norway and I'm a third-year
student I'm looking for a job for the
next year after this research is usually
affected by the oil price existing oil
rigs continue to operate as before so
the rock sole company says it still has
plenty of work raxil employs 130 people
and specializes in repairing pipe
systems for oil production the staff are
used to long hours lots of stress and
constant pressure from customers
the company's managers welcome the fact
that lower oil prices have slowed things
down a little in the industry they and
their staff have been working at full
capacity for years they say the pressure
is relentless the area is overheated I
think so it has been so much work doing
in the area and then the prices are kind
of an increasing increase increasing
just to force the companies to deliver
so for us I think it's a good start
anyway to turn up a little bit again but
the trade unions are not so optimistic
they're concerned that cost-cutting
measures and layoffs could be in the
pipeline and they feel that the low oil
price is a wake-up call for the entire
stoping a region they say the solution
is to diversify and reduce the region's
dependence on oil they're concerned
about long term economic decline and
they're calling for investment in other
industries so they must use the surplus
the wealth to invest in research and
development to find other income and
other technological solutions that can
take the lead from the fossil economy
and into a green economy Norway's
largest energy groups oil recently
posted its first quarterly loss in 13
years shares in the company which is
majority state-owned have lost 20% of
their value over the last six months
Stano oil declined to talk on camera oil
market analyst Bjorn Vidar Liron knows
the managers at städel and says cuts are
in the works but it's not yet clear in
which area
for many years we have been on a very
very high rate of investment
particularly the last 2-3 years it had
been almost artificial high so sooner or
later we had to see some Corrections and
adjustment I think this is of course
boosted by by the falling oil price back
at the port Moran Scotland is busy
loading equipment for the oil rigs she's
been doing this job for four years now
and she hopes to be able to stick with
it for a long time to come